we still technically have not really
decided the controversy of whether
s'mores are overrated
they're good they're delicious we'll see
eduardo you
say it i'm not a fan exactly
kind of i know but eduardo kind of
tipped it but it wasn't 100 no guess
what it was can i
quite honestly all roofing aside with
that assembled group of crew people that
were there
most people
were underwhelmed by the concept of a
s'more seriously that's i just edited
that episode and it was pretty much 50
50 until eduardo weighed in and kind of
skewed it to that they are overrated but
it was close most of the people who
liked it though connect it with a nice
happy experience so maybe you just
haven't had any happy experience no i i
think again i'll go back to it s'mores
are all about given that we're here
around a campfire and no one brought a
decent treat this will do i think
s'mores survive in the national
consciousness because people are grating
on a curve
they're saying given that all we have
are some old crackers
and some
uh not terrific chocolate and some
marshmallows a very inferior treat
and some sticks
uh this isn't bad i have to agree yes
that is what we're talking about with
s'mores i highly disagree i just think
you can
make it exactly the way you want it you
want to char the marshmallow cool if you
don't want to char it and you just want
to gradually melt it cool if you want
whatever kind of chocolate that's cool
even if you do it all perfectly you end
up with a c minus dessert
you just do
you know it's like a pirate saying has a
peg leg made of wood he didn't even know
that one day there'd be these amazing
prosthetics no he's just like ah
for you know hey i mean all your choice
be
no leg at all i'll take the pig this is
the dumbest analogy that is the smith
analogy is this no the s'more is the peg
leg
of treats
okay well i'm on the s'more side now
suddenly oh
yeah
yes i can't be having uh aluminum
fiberglass and carbon prosthetic made
with the latest technology i guess i'll
take a piece of wood because it's
either either that you're tipping over
ah
i agree see even the parrot agrees ah
suck
if a s'more is all we have then that's
what we'll have but if someone had a
better treat like a baked alaska well
i'd be first in line
what other treats have you had around a
campfire that are better baked alaska oh
how about the chocolate-covered
honeycomb and bourbon that was actually
really good no but that's pre-pa that's
prepared what are you saying is what do
you make with the fire you're i know
you're grating on a curve you keep
saying but no one's ever come up with
anything better because it's perfect it
is not amanda made something called
banana boats where you split a banana
down the middle and put nutella in wrap
it and foil and put that on i would eat
that i would eat that because i would
tell you i would eat that that sounds
fantastic yeah i would eat that next
year we'll try that maybe in the hot tub
but i mean just remember
that
s'mores only live on the consciousness
because no one had a better idea at the
time
i think if they were really as bad as
you say they were then not many people
would just have completed they do it
because they they don't have adoration
for it it's a false memory they think
they're supposed to love it that's the
point they think they're supposed to
like us more because it's supposed to
connect them to this pure american
experience out in the woods and it's
[ __ ] what we're dealing with here is
progression versus tradition and this is
the new culture war yeah the war on
christmas this is s'mores is now the new
culture war
i think i think you're that's a very you
just elevated this whole conversation
you have terrible analogies your peg leg
wine your war on christmas no it doesn't
work i'm sorry you try an analogy then
you big guy i uh i don't know i'm not
even going to think of an analogy
because i already know i'm not good at
them yeah
you win i'm not even going to try
because i know i'm no good well i knew
even if i did try it would be better
than the s'mores is like the peg legs of
of desserts all i can think of now is a
pirate who doesn't have a peg leg but
instead he's assembled a bunch of
s'mores
to
stack them and he's trying to support
his body on the s'mores and then he
caught his foot in the fire yeah
he's standing too close to a fire and
he's like have asked he swabs
and he falls over i'm delicious
i just take delish i just ate my leg and
it's underwhelming